Let me show you my solution. First of all, notice in BlueJ, that the dog,
house, and car class, implement a drawable interface. You see that with these
little arrows with a triangle on the end. If we open up one of them then we'll
see the implements class over here. Now let's look at the scene class. Note
that we now have a single ArrayList, everything gets added to that one
ArrayList and we just have one loop. So you can see how interfaces dramatically
simplified this program. What made it all work? The fact that you can convert
from an object of a class to the interface type. In this case drawable. And so
all these elements were convertible to drawable and then to draw them we can
invoke the draw method on each element. We know they all have a draw method
because they're all drawables. Sara has a few exercises prepared to make sure
that you understand when you can and when you can't convert between two types.
And then, she will show you a new interface that expresses when an item is
likable in a social network.